apparently and I want to apologize in
advance but apparently you did a sketch
for us many many many years ago when you
were struggling actor isn't that right
yeah it was uh it was one of my first
jobs oh okay this is in New York on the
old late night show yes the old show
yeah you were there I was there yeah
well you are there when we shot the the
actual it wasn't there yeah yeah yeah I
went away I went away for a while no no
he was saying that you when you when he
shot the sketch at rehearsal you were
probably not there you always came in at
the last second drunk out of your mind
yeah that's why I went away for a few
yeah what was the sketch well apparently
you you it was a running gag that you
guys used to do where it was right at
the advent of satellite TV that's all
trust me I know I used to make fun of
the wheel when it first came out yeah
sometime in the mid 90s and the gag was
that there was all these new channels
that were coming out and I think it was
around the time of it I believe like TLC
had come out and The Cooking Channel of
the Food Channel and we would do
arbitrary little I remember this we
would do arbitrary like oh there's
another cable channel and would just be
something really specific and really
stupid and awful yes and then it would
you would hit the remote and then it
would be lip around and my channel was
masturbating team
and I remember getting the call getting
you at all I love how I love how you
made it sound like you've just been made
a Supreme Court judge
well you when you're a struggling actor
in New York he tapped me yeah the Conan
O'Brien show calls and says you're the
one kid I said all right where do I
masturbate and so I get there and and I
remember shooting it and they're like
okay so you know you people disappoint
me as a group you really really
disappointment go ahead so I remember in
the director was like okay so get
underneath the covers I'm like all right
and and what will happen is that we're
gonna protect we're gonna whip the
camera around and we're gonna pretend
like we're your mom walking in cameras
your mom yes yes and you're supposed to
say mom what are you doing get out of
here Yeah right and then it turns out
that you're the mom right and I remember
sitting there as this is happening
pretending to masturbate underneath this
comforter and thinking who are the other
adults in charge of this aren't there
grown people that think that this is
going to get on the air because I don't
think that it is and and luckily and I
and yet I went through the process and
and luckily better taste prevailed and
it did not make the cut it probably
didn't that night but I'm sure we used
it it's out there somewhere let's know
we used to it we used to cut some things
but not because it was in poor taste
that was probably not the reason it got
cut
it was probably there was a technical
problem I'd love to say that oh no our
bar was too high for that but absolutely
not
absolutely not yeah well I remember
thinking like I'm not gonna tell anybody
about this and was one of my first jobs
and you usually excited like hey mom dad
watch me on TV
yeah how do you think I felt with my
parents I was hosting that [ __ ] very
hard for me to say I don't know what's
going on on that program I'd have no
control on the Conan show